>>Joe: I'm Joe Fernandez and welcome to Android
Developer Office Hours.
Joining me is Trevor Johns.
>>Trevor: Howdy.
>>Joe: And in a little while we'll have our
special guest James Dong from the Media Framework
team.
Um.
As a reminder, folks who've got questions
please join us in the Hangout and we can take
your questions live.
We do like to talk to real heads every once
in a while.
To get started though we'll look at the questions
in the Moderator queue.
If you've got questions, please post them
there.
And if you like the questions in there, plug
them up for the ones that you wanna hear the
answer to.
So first one we've got is from "Whiteout"
in Oklahoma.
And he asks "As a follow on to the question
asked today on the EMEA show about the issue
tracker, focusing on the most starred issues
may make sense for enhancements but for defects
that doesn't seem effective.
How about setting up a triage team from the
community?"
>>Trevor: Alright.
For those of you who were not watching the
EMEA Office Hours, the question was basically,
how are bugs in the Android issue tracker?
Which by the way is located at b.Android.com.
So it's, like "bugs", b.Android.com.
And the answer was that we look at them, there
are a lot of issues there.
And we look at them primarily by number of
stars.
Which is what we use as our voting mechanism.
So if issues get a lot of stars they bubble
up to the top and they get the most attention.
Of course, we do try and take a look at all
bugs, but some get, of course, some more attention
than others.
So, and the, yeah, so as far as does that
make sense for defects?
I think sometimes it does.
There certainly are some really annoying defects
that impact a lot of people.
And it's good to go and make sure there's
a way to go and get, have a way to voice that
you need those fixed.
And so I think stars work really well for
that.
That being said, you know, sometimes there
are some bugs that don't impact a lot of people.
But the few people it impacts, there is, it's
still worth fixing.
Because it's a annoyance to that small number
of people.
Right?
If it's a blocking bug.
If it prevents you from building something.
If you can't stream media.
If you can't, just for an example, that should
be fixed.
Probably, a little bit quicker than something
that's more of a cosmetic change.
So in those cases, I mean we still do take
a look at pretty much every bug when it comes
in.
We need to go, we assign them, we do do initial
triage.
So, yes, even though we do look at the starred
issues first, we do look at all the bugs.
I'm not sure that we really need to add another
level of triage on there, since we're already
doing another level internally.
But that being said, I'll certainly go ahead
and pass this along to the rest of the team
and see if management likes that idea.
And you know, it's possible it could go somewhere.
We'll see.
>>Joe: Cool.
>>Trevor: So, feature request noted.
[chuckles]
>>Joe: [chuckles] Great.
Alright.
Thanks for that question.
And next up we've got "Bro Software Design"
in Lucca, Italy.
Uh.
Who asks, "AudioRecord and AudioTrack are
high, are critical cpu demanding classes.
I experienced distorted and choppy audio in
my VOIP app.
Voice over IP.
Are there best practices or patterns of use
to help avoid these problems?
Deep specs on the internal behavior would
help."
Uh, that's a good question.
>>Trevor: OK.
>>Joe: A little bit out of my league.
How about you?
>>Trevor: Yeah, I can speak a little bit on
that one.
So, we edited the low latency audio paths
in Jellybean.
But this is primarily for playback.
For recording there's not really a really
good low latency path yet.
AudioRecord is the best one available.
And it does work.
But you just have to be super careful when
you use it.
The most important thing is to make sure you
pick your buffer sizes carefully.
And keep in mind that those buffer sizes will
change on a device by device basis.
So there are some methods there, you can go
and use to try and figure out what size buffer
is appropriate for the device you're on.
And that will help go and avoid some of those
stuttering issues that you're running into.
And hopefully at some point in the future
we'll go and add some more APIs or improve
the existing APIs.
It'll help improve latency there as well.
But latency shouldn't cause distortion, right?
Latency is more of, you'll have a little bit
of lag.
Yeah.
Choppy audio.
Almost exclusively is a buffer problem.
So check your buffer sizes.
Now that said, since you are doing a voice
over IP app, I will also point out that Android
has a built in SIP stack already.
And you might wanna consider reusing that.
Especially if you are talking to a SIP server.
Which a lot of voice over IP apps are.
And you can just go ahead and tie it to that
and then have the OS handle all over your
audio decoding and encoding.
Instead of just a server for you.
And then all you have to do is write a UI
on top of that.
So if that makes sense, definitely something
to look into as well.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Thanks for that.
Do we have anybody in the Hangout for questions?
>>Male Engineer: Uh, not yet.
>>Joe: OK.
Alright.
So, next up we've got uh, Marcus in Europe.
Asks, "How do we, how to determine if a specific
audio recording, say, AMR-WV is supported
for encoding?
AudioCodec has no constant for AMR-WV and
others.
Background, at least Experia X10 has no AMR,
doesn't have this format.
And need to detect this as, or else the app
just crashes in native C."
Alright, so detecting audio format supported
on a specific device which is, I guess it
is a device specific.
>>Trevor: Well, there is, I seem to recall
there is a "Get Codecs" method that will go
and tell you what codecs are present.
And I can't remember if there's a way to go
in, I think there's a way to distinguish between
AMR wide band and narrow band.
So I'm pretty sure that would work there as
well.
So even if you—
>>Joe: So there's no constant for it there?
Or?
>>Trevor: Um.
>>Joe: That's very interesting.
>>Trevor: No, well there is, there's just
a generic constant for AMR if I remember correctly.
>>Joe: Oh, that's the AMR, oh, OK.
The specific brand of AMR.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
The, the flavor of AMR.
Yes.
>>Joe: Right.
OK.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
I'm not sure how you're disassociating the
two different types of AMR.
I'm sure there's a way to go and distinguish
between them.
If you post a StackOverflow question we can
go ahead and look into that a little bit more.
But in general the correct approach is to
go and call "Get Codecs" and check which codecs
are present.
And that'll at least get you as far as AMR.
And, we'll try and find some information about
how to distinguish between the two different
flavors of AMR for you.
>>Joe: Right.
Thanks for that question.
Uh, let's see what else we've got here.
Marcus also asks "Will there be support for
streaming, uh, capable container format?"
capable container format.
"In MediaRecorder.
Like MPEG-TS."
Let's see.
"In the future."
Capable container format.
I'm not sure what he's asking there.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I'm not familiar with MPEG-TS
myself.
This is probably a good question for our guest
when he finally arrives.
[Joe laughs]
So let's come back to this one in a bit.
>>Joe: OK.
Let's move up here.
Alright.
Alex asks, I would love to see more working
code samples in the documentation."
Yes.
You and many other people actually.
Uh "More specifically, if we take a good look
at the code that was presented at Google IO
2012.
We can see that it had a lot of mistakes and
all of them were copy-pasted to the Developers
documentation."
[Trevor laughs]
I'm not sure that that's actually true.
Uh.
It may seem like the stuff that you're working
on was copy-pasted from the Developers documentation.
We do use our documentation extensively to
build our samples and code samples.
And unfortunately when we write them sometimes
we make mistakes.
So definitely appreciate the feedback on that.
But more helpful would be putting out some
of those issues.
Certainly you can go to b.Android.com and
file some bugs on that one.
We definitely would look at that for documentation
errors.
Coding errors.
And all that stuff.
So.
Appreciate the feedback.
And—
>>Trevor: And if you're feeling a bit more
adventurous too, I'll point out you actually
can go and modify all the docs yourself.
We don't normally point it out too heavily.
Because our documentation system could be
ea little nicer.
But if you look in the source tree under "frameworks
base docs html", everything is in there with
the DOC JD extension.
And you can make a change, or also javadocs
as well for the API reference.
And if you send us a patch in [inaudible].
Especially for, you know, anything that's
an error.
We definitely would love to have a patch to
go and fix that.
But that said, that shouldn't stop you from
filing a bug.
Right?
We'd much rather have a bug than nothing at
all.
So either way, let us know if you do discover
an error.
And you know, whether us by patch, or us fixing
it for you, we wanna go and get that documentation
straightened out.
>>Joe: Yeah, so definitely do file a bug if
you're feeling more adventurous like Trevor
said, you can go ahead and actually make a
change and file a patch.
And we'll take a look at that.
But you know, please do tell us about the
stuff that is missing.
Or incorrect.
We're always working on improvements to the
documentation.
So we do appreciate that feedback.
And we definitely take a look at that when
folks file bugs.
So.
Please give us more feedback.
We appreciate it.
Alright let's move on to Marcus is very popular
with the questions today.
Again, from Europe.
He's asking "can a new video recording start
exactly where a previous one ends?"
>>Trevor: I wanna say not likely.
Because just, you're gonna have to stop the
video recording.
Start the video recording.
And in between that time, some number of milliseconds
will pass while you're performing operations.
I think the best option would be to go and
have a single continuous recording and then
trim it up afterwards.
Or ultimately record it to some in-memory
store.
And then just go and splice it in memory.
I think if you're just going and writing that
to a file, and you're trying to switch files,
there's gonna be overhead there.
And it's not gonna start and stop exactly
where you left off.
On top of that, I think when you stop recording
the video's gonna close the camera connection
as well.
Which is gonna add additional lag when the
camera needs to be reinitialized.
>>Joe: Yeah.
Probably wanna do a different approach there.
Maybe you're putting bookmarks or noting particular
tags in the file, just, for example a time
stamp that says "Alright, here's the end of
one clip and the beginning of a new one."
Rather than like starting and stopping the
video recording.
As Trevor says, that start stop problem has
a lot of lag to it.
And there's some overhead that you're gonna
incur as soon as you stop and start something.
Um, alright.
So, another question from Marcus.
Let's see if we've added some other folks
to talk about here.
Let's see.
"Anon" says, as anonymous, I suppose?
>>Trevor: I imagine, yeah.
>>Joe: Anon, our favorite contributor says,
"Shortcuts were retconned" I don't even know
what that word means.
[laughs]
>>Trevor: Retroactively added to continuity.
Basically it's changing the past.
[laughs]
>>Joe: [laughs] OK.
So "Were added into widgets in four point
oh.
Was it intentional that they aren't part of
the new Jellybean widget design guidelines?
Are we phasing them out, discouraging their
use, since they don't get mentioned in the
new dev site either?"
>>Trevor: So, yeah are definitely something
that we're not heavily promoting right now.
And in favor of widgets.
So yeah, I'd say there is definitely a reason
why they're not mentioned in our, in the new
design guidelines as well as not featured
as prominently in the API documentation as
well either.
So, yeah.
We pretty much in all pieces we're recommending
you go with a widget where you'd previously
used a shortcut.
>>Joe: Gotcha.
Alright.
Thanks for that one.
Marcus, our very popular poster today.
Again asks, "Why does a camera need to be
visible on the screen to be recorded?"
I wasn't aware that that's actually a requirement.
Although I know that for the camera anyway,
that's usually the behavior that we think.
And that's [unintelligible].
>>Trevor: I'd say it's probably one of two
things.
Either it was a conscious decision by the
media team to make sure that the user knows
something is being recorded.
Or alternatively it was just an oversight
in our design and hasn't been addressed yet.
Without having someone in the room who actually
wrote the camera API, I can't tell you for
sure.
[Joe laughs]
But either one sounds plausible to me.
So sorry I don't have an authoritative answer
for you there.
>>Joe: Yeah.
Having talked to a few of the guys on the,
who work on the camera team, I'm guessing
that that was a design choice initially.
Since we do want folks to be able to see what
they're actually recording as they're, got
the camera on.
I have seen apps, at least one app that I've
used myself for doing something like a camera
surveillance that you can turn off the thing.
Although I believe what's going on is that
the video preview is just not being shown
onscreen.
It's actually still playing in the background.
So, believe that's a design issue.
But again, since we don't have the media team
with us and James to ask that question, we're
speculating a little bit there.
Alright.
Um.
>>Male Engineer: Alright guys, I've actually
got a question.
From someone on the Hangout.
I'm gonna put them on for you right now.
>>Joe: Alright.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Sure.
Let's hear it.
>>Joe: [unintelligible] has a question.
Yes please.
Hello, go ahead.
[feedback]
>>Male Engineer: He actually has no video.
So it's going to be—
>>Trevor: I think that's alright, yeah, go
ahead.
>>Male #1: [unintelligible]
>>Trevor: Yeah, we can hear you.
>>Male #1: Hi everybody.
>>Joe: Hi.
>>Trevor: Howdy.
>>Male #1: I had a question about encoding
the capabilities with the new media API.
And I tried it already and decoder stuff works
great.
So I put a video to the, um, coded, and it
decoded with no problems.
And it rendered in the surface.
But when it tried to create encoder, it tells
me that some uh, exception, raised in the
native code in the open mocks I guess.
And the error code is 38 and it says that
some parameters are not specified.
And that's it.
I just simply can't create encoder.
So probably I'm doing something wrong but
there is nothing about it in documentation
and I'm just stuck.
[loud feedback]
So I just have a real problem here.
So I can decode video here but I cannot encode.
So this is main problem.
>>Trevor: Uh, yeah I'd say that the first
step to debugging that is to try to figure
out what a code 38 error is.
I know there are a number of numeric errors
like that can happen when you work with the
media APIs and as much as I hate telling people
"look at the source" it is actually the best
way to figure out what's causing that.
So if you take a look at the Android source
code and search for that error, you can actually
find out what the condition is that causes
it.
And that'll tell you where to go and look.
You know, my guess is it's probably something
to do with your encoding settings.
Possibly, maybe it's an unsupported codec
on the device, something like that.
Yeah.
>>Joe: [unintelligible]
>>Trevor: Documentation probably should be
a bit better there so I apologize for that.
But that's usually what I wind up doing when
I run into those.
>>Joe: Have you tried this on multiple devices?
Is it the same error?
Or just one the one specific device?
>>Male #1: Yes, to multiple devices.
And it's the same error.
And I tried to create it with different codecs
from my which were available in the system
and three GP or AVC in batch four.
So the same error.
And nothing else.
So I don't, I also supplied different sets
of parameters for codec.
And it did not help either.
So, uh.
OK.
Then I will take a look into NDK with OpenMaxium
and probably there is some description of
it.
>>Joe: Yeah.
If you can, put a, post something on StackOverflow
so we can get a little bit more detail on
that.
Having worked with some of the media stuff
myself, I know it's very finicky.
Run into some issues myself.
Not even using the more recent APIs.
So if you can give us a little bit more detail
on that we could hopefully follow up and talk
to the media team and see what's going on
there.
>>Male #1: OK.
>>Joe: It's probably, there might be just
a bit you're not flipping that isn't obvious
to you or us.
So let's certainly follow up with you on that
one too.
>>Male #1: And I have also one question, I
was trying to create some filters for the
camera.
And I looked into the source code.
And as you know for sure we have several possible
filters for the camera, and they depend on
the manufacturer.
So different devices have different sets of
filters that we can apply to the camera.
And I was, mm, browsing the source code.
And actually I did not find any implementation
of the filters.
So I could find the constants, stains, kind
of sepia, or black and white, etcetera, etcetera.
But I could not find the implementation of
this filters themself in the native code anywhere.
So can you [pause]
>>Joe: oop.
>>Trevor: I think we missed the end of your
question there.
[Hangout "dings" multiple times]
>>Male Engineer: There's some issues with
the Hangout right now.
[Hangout "dinging"]
I'm going to turn it off.
So.
>>Joe: oh-oh.
We got cut off.
>>Trevor: Right, well if you happen to get
back on, or if you just wanna leave a comment
on the Google plus post as well would work
too.
So that way we can actually answer your question
while it's there.
Sounds like we missed the very end and so
we're not sure what you're actually trying
to ask.
>>Joe: So it sounded to me like [Hangout dings]
what he was finding is that the filters, some
of the different camera filters that you can
apply to the camera, so like sepia is one
of them.
I think there's like "posterize" and some
other things that are kind of like standard
image filters there.
That there wasn't actually source code for
that when he was looking at the platform.
Um.
My guess is that that's as expected.
That the camera operations and the different
filters are actually implemented by the manufacturers.
That that source code, the custom source code
developed by the folks who actually built
the camera and put the device together.
So probably what you're looking at is having
to do, if you're, I think the goal was, I'm
guessing that the goal was to make his own
filters and try to do that stuff.
I know that that's possible.
'cause I've seen a couple different camera
apps that do something like that.
Though, being able to take the manufacturers
source code, I don't think they're gonna be
able to do that right now.
[chuckles] So.
Anyway.
If we can, if you manage to get back on and
ask us, 'cause I'm not sure we got actual
what your question was.
>>Male Engineer: I think we fixed the sound
issue.
Could you try speaking again from the Hangout?
And see if you're on air again?
[pause]
>>Joe: Not hearing you.
>>Male Engineer: Yeah.
He's, it's fine.
He said "OK.
Thanks."
>>Trevor: OK.
So I think we got his question then.
>>Joe: OK.
Thanks for the question.
Appreciate it.
Any more Hangout questions?
>>Male Engineer: Uh, not at the moment.
>>Joe: OK.
Please feel free to jump on and talk to us
in person.
We'll be glad to talk to you about it.
Let's see, do we have any more questions from
someone who is not Marcus.
[laughter]
Let's see, we've got Frank Spazario?
Spasaro . Asks, "I want to choose a photo
from the gallery.
No problems if a local image is chosen.
However a Picasa photo returns a URI instead
of a location.
Is there an approved way of handling this?
Can I modify my intent to only show local
images?"
>>Trevor: So I would recommend against doing
that.
Because photos coming from Picasa are still
photos that belong to the user.
And it's something they might wanna pick.
And you should still have them.
So the answer here is, just make sure that
you know, whatever URL you get back whether
it's a content URL or a file URL or an HTV
URL, treat it as a URL and decode it properly.
Right.
If it's HD URL you should go and fetch the
image from the network and display it.
Yeah, that's the proper way to do it.
So I don't think there's a really good way
to go and say you don't want those images
from other sources.
Because they are there for a reason.
It's something the user can select.
>>Joe: Right.
Yeah, so I think the answer is, yeah you probably
could do that.
But we prefer that you make your app more
awesome and actually handle all the images
that the user has access to.
'Cause that'll give them all the choices that
they want.
So good question.
We'll take a little slightly different tack
on that one.
Alright, so moving on to our next question.
Julius from Auckland says "Can you recommend
a way to implement gapless music playback,
e.g. loading two files and not experiencing
a gap."
So like doing a cross-fade basically.
"And API seven plus" So API seven and up.
"I am currently thinking of using an input
stream or something."
Hmm.
Interesting question.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
I'm sure there's gotta be a way to do it.
What's the name of that API?
[laughs]
[Joe laughs]
Shoot I'm suddenly drawing a blank on the
API that you'd wanna use for that.
>>Joe: I don't know it either.
Extreme?
>>Trevor: Yeah I think we're gonna have to
get back to you on that one.
Again, if you can post a question on StackOverflow
we'll go ahead and try and get you some more
information after the show.
Unless, Reto, you happen to know the answer
off the top of your head.
No.
I'm getting a no from off camera.
>>Joe: Headshake.
No.
That's a no.
We'll have to get back to James on that one.
>>Trevor: Yeah, if you've stumped Reto you
know you've asked a tough question.
>>Joe: Another question from "Anon."
"Dave" Who's Dave.
We're not Dave.
Are you Dave?
>>Trevor: Uh, Dave Burke.
Who was supposed to join us today but unfortunately
had a conflict.
So.
>>Joe: Ah.
>>Trevor: We do have other members of the
media team who are supposed to join us at
some point during the show [Joe laughs] so
this is another question that we can go and
revisit once we have somebody here.
>>Joe: There you go.
Alright.
So, "Dave" who is not here.
"What would you say are the most exciting
capabilities use cases that are enabled by
the new four point one audio APIs that weren't
possible beforehand?"
Hmm.
>>Trevor: I think this is a question for the
media team.
So.
Let's revisit this one I think.
Unless you know?
>>Joe: yeah, well I mean, I think the most
important features that they added with four
point one were the low latency APIs.
So being able to play audio very quickly versus
having a little bit of a delay actually in
the previous versions.
I think it's like, probably the most important
improvement they put in there.
There are some other ones as well.
But again, I feel like I'm not the right question
for me.
So there's a piece of an answer there anyway.
Um, there's some other interesting stuff if
you look at the developer site and look at
their release notes for four point one.
We do have a section on the midi APIs and
some of the changes there.
So it's' a way to go get some of that information.
And if Dave shows up we'll definitely come
back and ask that question.
>>Trevor: Or, for that matter, if anyone from
the media team—
>>Joe: Shows up.
Or anyone from the media team.
Yes.
Media team please come and see us.
Let's see.
Moving on.
We've got another question from Mark in Virginia.
"Can you speak to using the DRM API in conjunction
with the media APIs to first apply DRM to
a video, then verify it and play it back?
This might be too complex a topic for the
Hangout."
Yeah, you might be correct in that.
"Maybe a blog post or pointers to example
code?"
>>Trevor: Yeah.
So the DRM API code is really designed more
for DRM schemes that are included as part
of the device.
So if you're writing your own DRM scheme from
scratch, honestly, I don't think you're gonna
find the built in DRM APIs very useful for
that.
That's just been my experience.
It's possible that there's a better way to
use them that I've never heard about.
But usually when you do use that the DRM provider
has to be part of the system initially.
>>Joe: Yeah.
And yeah.
So I think that's all we've got to say about
that one for today.
Another question for Dave.
Who's not here.
From Anonymous.
"Dave, what kind of hardware disqualifies
a four point one plus device from being able
to support the new audio effects APIs?
IE: Would it be possible to preemptively predict
whether a device supports it or not just figure
out from its hardware specs?"
Essentially.
Um.
Hum.
Another good question.
Support the new audio effects.
Yeah, that is, it sort of sounds like there's
a hardware limitation based on what's been
implemented by the manufacturer in terms of
audio.
>>Trevor: Right.
Somehow I doubt it's gonna be just a matter
of looking at the hardware specs.
I imagine there are some driver issues involved
as well too.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: So I'm not sure that just looking
at the hardware specs would give you enough
information to determine whether or not audio
effects are possible or not.
[pause]
>>Joe: Alright.
Let's see, moving on.
"Browen Software Design" in Lucca Italy asks
again, "Android API greater than or equal
to 12.
Android" This is a very complex question here.
[Trevor laughs]
>>Joe: Android.net.rtp AudioGroup and AudioStream.
"Are there examples of tutorial of this, of
use of this.
My APIs documentation is essential for such
a rich APIs."
Uh.[muttering] RealTime.
>>Trevor: Yeah, so, RTP streaming, basically.
>>Joe: RTP streaming.
As far as I'm aware of, no, not yet.
But that's some good feedback to take back
to the team.
I know they wanna do some more coverage on
this but I don't think there's nothing out
there right now.
And that's probably why he's asking the question.
>>Trevor: Right.
There are some, um, StackOverflow questions
asking a very similar thing to what you just
asked.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: And there is some user provided
sample code.
It's not the same as something provided officially.
So again, it's very good feedback and something
we'll take back to the rest of the team.
But for now, I'd go in and look at that if
you need an example of how to use RTP.
>>Joe: Fair enough.
>>Reto: We have a question from Jeff Simmons
on the G plus stream.
>>Joe: Sure.
>>Reto: He wants to know "Is it possible to
use a menu codec with audio record to RealTime
compression from the mic?"
>>Trevor: So, media codec with AudioRecord
to do RealTime compression.
Um.
That's a good question actually.
I've never tried it myself.
I wanna say it's probably possible at some
level.
Given that you know, whenever you select a
codec there's a certain amount of compression
and processing that's done at that time anyway.
So, short answer is "probably" but I think
we need somebody from the media team in here
to actually go and explain a little bit more
about what's involved in doing that.
Since I don't think anyone here has actually
ever tried it.
But.
>>Joe: Yes.
So.
Good question, but unfortunately we're a little
out of our depth on that one.
Let's see, any other questions from the Hangout?
No?
OK.
Got a headshake there.
Julius from Auckland asks "Is there a way
to calculate the duration of the audio produced
by a text to speech request?
Currently we have to push audio to a file
to get the duration from the file.
We wish to supply the user with a visual indicator
of the length in advance."
Hm.
That's a very interesting one.
>>Trevor: Hm.
It is.
And somehow my gut feeling is probably not,
'cause usually when you're using the text
to speech API is you're doing it to play it
back immediately.
And you know, for example driving directions
in GoogleMaps.
You just have a voice that's reading off directions
to you.
And it's very much just "take my text and
read it and I wanna be done" so I don't think
there's much in the way of the API there for
things like getting the length.
Things like that.
So I suspect what you're doing is probably
the best way to do it.
I can't say that authoritatively.
But my gut feeling is that's probably the
best way to do it right now.
>>Joe: Alright.
Thanks for that question Julius.
And now we've got another one.
From Ihear Joff?
Or Geoff?
From Seattle, Washington.
"Is it possible to use the MediaCodec class
in conjunction with AudioRecord?"
That sounds like the same question.
>>Trevor: It does.
[Joe laughs]
And I suspect it is.
>>Joe: Probably the same.
>>Trevor: But we need actually his name from
the team to confirm that.
>>Joe: OK.
Uh.
>>Reto: Just so you guys know, James from
the Media Team is currently hurriedly trying
to grab a last bit at lunch and he will hopefully
be up here at least for the last 15 minutes.
[laughter]
So.
He's, uh—
>>Joe: These media guys and their lunches.
[inaudible]
>>Reto: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: Tell, tell him that Joe's open.
>>Joe: Unbelievable.
>>Trevor: He can get a sandwich.
[laughter]
After the show.
>>Joe: Alright, moving along here.
We've got from Tomas Skare in Arvika, Sweden.
Alright.
Somebody from Sweden.
Excellent.
"we've been, when using the MHL adapter to
get HDMI out, some apps like YouTube show
different views to the device display and
the HDMI output.
How is that done?
I could not find any API for this.
Is it hardware dependent?"
>>Trevor: Alright.
I actually do know the answer to this one.
>>Joe: Alright.
Awesome.
>>Trevor: I was talking, it came up a couple
weeks ago.
So.
The answer is, there is support in the system
specifically for video services.
And HDMI output.
So it is a manufacturer specific setting.
So not all Android devices are guaranteed
to do this.
Even if they're running the latest version.
But at least on the versions that Google has
produced whenever you have a video service
on the screen, the contents of that video
service will be used as the HDMI output.
So it's not an API that's available for developers.
Other than to just use the system media APIs.
And if you do that, whenever you have video
on screen, it should be mirrored over HDMI.
>>Joe: Alright.
So it's specifically keyed to the video servers.
>>Trevor: That's correct.
>>Joe: Got it.
But only on certain devices?
>>Trevor: Only on certain devices.
Other devices might handle it differently.
They might choose to provide their own private
APIs.
They could go and just use mirroring all the
time.
It really just depends on what the manufacturer
wants for their HDMI output.
>>Joe: Alright.
Great.
Good question.
Thank you, Tomas.
And.
Next we have Marcus from Europe has been very
productive today with his questions.
"when will the camera service ever auto-unlock
or how will unlock when it, how unlock it
when it have crashes of the app crash still
holds the lock and blocks all other apps from
using the camera until the phone reboots?"
Yes.
This is a problem.
So for those of you who have done some development
in camera, with the camera as I have, if you
write bad code and you have errors in your
code and your camera crashes without you actually
unlocking the camera app, or access to the
camera, yes, you will lock out not only yourself
but anybody else and any other apps that try
to use the camera because that lock has not
been un, not um, apparently released.
Probably the first answer is, make sure your
app doesn't crash in the middle of using the
camera.
You know, test your code thoroughly to make
sure that this doesn't happen.
Because that is in fact I think the only way
you can really unlock it if that kind of error
occurs.
I think even if you put in, it's probably
a good idea to have in your code, in one of
your on pause or what's the other, the final
on destroy?
To make sure that, to check that you've done
a release of the camera object before your
app actually exits.
So make sure that that code's in there.
In fact, you can see an example of that code
when you look at the developer guide for camera.
So make sure you put that into your code.
But really the only other answer is if your
app is crashing and misbehaving then, yeah,
you're gonna cause that kind of a problem.
And you're gonna upset your users.
So make sure you test that kind of an app
thoroughly and make sure that that doesn't
happen.
Any other thoughts?
>>Trevor: I think that explained pretty thoroughly.
I don't have anything else to add to that.
[laughs]
>>Joe: OK.
Alright.
Good question, thank you sir.
>>Male Engineer: I've actually got Alexander
back on the Hangout.
He wants to chime back in about cameras and
whatnot?
So wanna put him on from the Hangout?
>>Joe: Great.
Go ahead Alexander.
>>Male Engineer: Alex, go ahead.
You're on.
>>Alex: Hi, guys again.
So, I wanna—
>>Joe: [inaudible]settings.
>>Trevor: Can't hear him.
Check the monitor settings.
>>Joe: Sorry Alex.
We're getting a little—
>>Alex:Oh, can you hear me?
>>Male Engineer: I'm getting it from, Alex
[inaudible]
>>Alex: Hello?
Hello?
>>Joe: Ah, there you go.
We can hear you now.
>>Male Engineer: There you go.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Alex: Good.
So as you know, if we want to process the
media as a picture from the camera in leaf,
we have really small FBFs coming back from
camera.
And this is really frustrating.
'cause if we want to make some exceptions,
some filters, etcetera, etcetera, we would
really like to have kind of real time stream.
And uh, do you guys plan to provide us with
such, I don't know, possibilities as a key
to process the stuff in native code, just
to gain more FBFs and etcetera etcetera.
So.
>>Joe: Yeah, so that's a good question.
There's actually three different ways that
I know of that you can get the different image
to the camera device whatever that camera
hardware is.
We only, the first one is pretty obvious.
But there's two additional ones that at least
I know of that you can use to get the frame,
the different frames from the camera.
In escalating levels of complexity, actually.
If you would, actually, and I actually, I'd
have to go back and look at my notes to kind
of explain some of those.
James who's come and joined us recently, can
talk about this stuff.
James, you wanna talk about different ways
that you could get different frames from the
camera?
I know there's a couple different approaches
that you can take.
>>James: Well, this is James.
I think in order to get the frames that are
from camera, there are a couple of ways.
One is you can use the preview callback, the
java API we published mandate, there are two
colors format must be supported.
One is [indistinct] the other is [indistinct].
So if you use preview frame callback, you
can have access to the frame data that way.
I think that's currently, if you use java
API, that's probably the only way.
And native layer, basically we have the recording
frame callback also.
You can gain access to the camera how recording
frames also.
Does this answer your question?
>>Alex: Can I get to the callback.
So I'm not sure that it's the command that's,
so, is there a way I can find it?
And put the listener on it?
>>James: Yeah.
There's steps involved.
Basically you just need to set a register
in callback.
Um, the callback is preview frame callback.
On the camera.java class.
And then the application should receive callbacks
from the camera.
Once the preview is—
>>Alex: Well, yes but, it's, the FPS is really
low there, so it's—
>>Joe: The frames per second.
>>Alex: Maximum can 10, 15 FPS.
Frames per seconds I can get from there.
And if I need to amend the data from it, it
becomes even slower.
So, I am really eager to find the way to make
it faster so.
I understand that we can use native stuff.
And for example.
If we look to the OpenCV project as a work
with camera.
>>James: Mm-hm.
>>Alex: And it's written purely in C as I
understand.
>>James: Mm-hm.
>>Alex: So I really hope you guys someday
decide to open such capabilities for us developers
so we could use at least 30 FPS for the camera.
>>James: Yes, I think you are right, when
you use this preview callback, the frame rate
is low.
The reason like the frame rate is low is because
the frame theater has to be copied out.
So there's a main copy involved.
We are working on some like enhancement to
the whole camera framework.
I cannot say for sure like when new API will
be available.
But definitely we are working on something
to improve in this regard for future API release.
Um, but not any time soon, like—
>>Alex: OK.
Thank you.
>>James: Sure.
>>Joe: Great.
And if you could post a question on this on
StackOverflow and I'll see if I can get you
a little bit more information.
I believe there's some other ways, other approaches
you can take to this.
But I can't talk about them off the top of
my head.
So just post a question on StackOverflow and
post it in the Hangout and I'll go follow
up with you there.
>>Reto: Now that we've actually got James
in the room do you think you may be able to
introduce yourself and tell the viewers a
little bit about who you are and what you
do in the Android team?
>>James: OK.
My name's James Dong.
I'm the tech lead for Android media team.
Basically, like our team is dealing with all
the media framework and camera framework.
Um, and we also have a separate team for audio
framework.
So, pretty much like a multimedia stuff.
Everything.
Thanks.
>>Joe: Great.
>>Reto: Very nice.
>>Joe: Thanks for joining us, James.
>>Reto: So a couple of questions we had queued
up from earlier on for James.
So while you guys look those up, I've got
one from Tom on the livestream.
He'd like to apply arbitrary effects to the
system media stream.
So things like creating the equalizer etcetera.
He can do this if he writes his own media
player.
But he'd really like to be able to just create
the effects and let users use whatever media
player they would usually use to apply those
effects.
Is that possible?
>>James: Um, the effects you want to apply
depends on how you get the frame in the first
place.
If you want to apply effects to the decoder
output, that's possible.
We just published a new media API called a
MediaCodec dot Java class.
Which allows you to gain access to the decoder
output directly.
And then you can do image processing on the
decoder output.
I think that's the, well, it really depends
on the context.
Like how you want to apply the effects.
So that's one way.
>>Reto: Thank you.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Don't put down that microphone just yet.
We've still got a few more questions for you,
James.
[laughter]
Scaling back to earlier question here.
How do I determine if there's a specific audio
encoding.
So AMR-WB rather than some of the other flavors
of the—
>>Trevor: Yeah, and AMR-NB.
>>Joe: AMR-NB.
And some of the other ones.
So AudioCodec get codec has no constant for
AMR-WB and others.
For example, the Experia X10 doesn't have,
doesn't support it.
And I wanna be able to detect that so, and
if I try to do that it actually crashes in
native C. So, this question is how to detect
if those formants are supported.
>>James: That's a great question and it comes
in a really timely fashion.
Like in Jellybean, we released this set for
new API, java APIs, one of the API allows
you to find out all the codecs available on
a specific device, Android device.
The class name is MediaCodecList.
And MediaCodecListInfo.
So using these two classes you can basically
walk through all the media codecs available
on a device.
And you can find out the capabilities of each
codec.
Such as whether this is AMR narrow band or
AMR wideband.
Whether this is like a AAC or any other video
codec.
For video codecs you can find out whether
like, what kind of profiles and levels supported
for that specific video codec.
So it is a new set of API we just published.
And it is very useful I think to you guys.
[pause]
>>Joe: Great.
Thanks for that.
>>James: Thank you.
>>Joe: Let's see, scrolling back to some previous
questions we had.
"Is it possible to use the MediaCodec class
in conjunction with AudioRecord?"
>>Trevor: Right, and we had a second question
which was very similar.
Is it possible to do compression when you're
using MediaRecord?
>>James: I think MediaCodec is designed in
a way that is generic so it's basically the
same set of API methods can be applicable
to both encoder and decoder.
So you should be able to use them for encoding
purpose also.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Let's see.
Marcus from Europe asked us "Will there be
support for any streaming capable container
format in MediaRecorder like MPEG-TS in the
future?"
Actually we can't answer that question because
that's a future-looking question.
>>Trevor: Right yeah.
That one we'll probably have to just skip.
I mean unless there's something you can share.
But generally speaking questions like this
we have to skip.
So.
>>Joe: Gotcha.
Alright, moving on.
There's another one we wanted.
>>Trevor: That one might be a good one to
revisit.
The camera.
>>Joe: Right, the camera question.
"Why does the camera need a visible surface
on the screen to be recorded?"
And is that actually true, is the next question.
>>James: Yeah, I think that this is true.
Currently for the java camera.java class we
have, the, this is due to a legacy reason.
Because like in the past we some of the [indistinct]
has to run a preview before they can supply
the video frames or preview frames.
So that's why we have to have that uh, available.
>>Joe: Gotcha.
OK.
So there's a little bit of a legacy problem
there.
>>James: yep.
>>Trevor: Yeah, OK.
So now we're actually back to new questions.
>>Joe: Alright.
And we're back to our regular questions.
Excellent.
>>Male Engineer: I've actually got a question
from the Hangout.
It's gonna be live and we'll have video this
time.
So [inaudible].
>>Trevor: Oh, yay.
We actually have someone with video.
>>Joe: Yay.
Actual live person.
Fantastic.
>>Male #2: yeah, I have a question on the
SDK manager.
I know there was a recent update 20 point
oh point three.
And I saw a new option there that says "enable
preview tools" so I tried checking that and
I'm not seeing the preview for Tools21.
Do you know if that's a new button that they
haven't put on, they haven't fixed yet?
Or 21 is not available for preview with the
SDK manager?
Do I need to file a bug?
>>Trevor: I don't believe 21 is available
yet.
So—
>>Male #2: It was released on the ninth.
>>Trevor: It was news to me that they have
the preview button there.
>>male #2: OK.
>>Trevor: I suspect probably sometime soon.
>>Male #2: The 21 preview was announced on
the ninth.
>>Trevor: Hm.
It should be up there.
Um.
>>Male #2: it's on the download page very
obscurely.
It's not listed on the main downloads.
But if you go to the bottom it's a subpage.
EDT21 preview requires the R21 preview.
>>Trevor: Just to check did you try refreshing
the SDK manager?
Because I know it does do some caching.
>>Male #2: I did, I turned off cache a while
ago because I had problems with caching.
And I think the newest update the 20 point
one three is supposed to fix the caching problem.
But—
[laughter]
>>Joe: Yes.
That's true, I've worked on those.
That's true.
>>Male #2: I did a clear download cache and
I've re—you know turned it off and on.
And—
>>Joe: Right.
Just a clue—
>>Reto: I wanted to check the, I'd have to
check the version numbers.
But is it possible that the reason you can't
see the preview is because the final version
got released a couple days ago?
>>Joe: I think actually I can answer this
question.
>>Male #2: Well, it's the preview of R21.
>>Joe: [indistinct] released.
Yeah.
>>Male #2: This is, I currently have 20 point
zero point three.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Male #2: of the SDK manager tool.
>>Joe: In general, so the tools guys, I actually
work with them quite a bit.
>>male #2: OK.
>>Joe: The previews, that doesn't actually
get released through the SDK manager.
>>Male #2: OK.
>>Joe: You have to go to tools.Android.com.
[inaudible]
>>male #2: Right.
That's how I got from the, this is on that
new preview button.
It said, log in and you get Tools through
that.
For the previews.
[Hangout dings]
>>Joe: Yeah, I think, I believe they're working
on a new feature to let you get the preview
through the SDK manager but I don't think
that's quite working yet.
>>male #2: OK.
That's probably why.
>>Joe: I know they've been busy working on
the 20 oh three release.
Because of that caching problem that you noticed.[inaudible]
>>Male #2: Right.
When twenty Oh three is out.
OK.
>>Joe: They've been very busy with that and
so I'm not surprised that there's no 21 preview
out at the moment.
So just stay tuned.
>>Male #2: OK.
>>Joe: I know those guys are working on quite
a few things.
So yeah, stay tuned on the Tools site.
That's where they'll announce it.
>>Male #2: Yeah.
Well the Tools site still lists—
>>Joe: And they'll announce it and then you
might be able to see it in the SDK manager
site.
>>Male #2: The Tools site still lists R19
as the latest release.
[laughs] [inaudible]
>>Joe: [inaudible] So, you know.
>>Male #2: That's a, pass it along.
To update the—
>>Joe: They're trying to do too many things
at once there.
>>Male #2: Probably, OK thanks.
>>Joe: Sure, thanks for the question.
Alright.
Let's see.
We've got—
>>Trevor: Nick.
>>Joe: a few more minutes to do questions.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: And Nick from Chicago asks, "Is it
possible to play audio backward?"
Wow, that's a very interesting question.
>>Trevor: Listening for hidden messages in
songs.
[laughter]
>>Joe: James, you wanna tackle that one.
Do we have an idea of that one, or?
We gonna have to punt on this?
[laughter]
>>James: [inaudible], Reto,
>>Reto: I can answer it partially.
You can play audio backwards if you're using
the AudioRecord and AudioPlay mechanisms.
I don't think you can do it using the MediaRecorder.
But if you're using the raw web files then
you can just flip the bits and play everything
in reverse order.
>>Joe: Alright.
Reto says it is possible.
So I believe him.
But only with which particular class?
>>Reto: The AudioRecord and AudioPlayback.
So that's for raw web audio, effectively.
So you can't just play an arbitrary song.
It needs to effectively be something you have
recorded with no encoding.
>>Joe: Got it.
So unencoded audio.
Probably encoded audio you're gonna be out
of luck.
You have to decode it first, probably.
Alright.
Great.
Nice question there.
Very interesting.
Uh, "RedneckRepublican" from Texas is joining
us and says "I see low level media API as
a good opportunity to save power on host devices.
Do we have any tips to make good use of the
API to do so.
Also is there a away to offload some pertaining
work to the GPU when using the low level,
the low media API?"
Uh.
Good question.
I see James shaking his head.
Do you have a answer to that one?
>>James: So, for this low-level [clears throat]
media API, I think one of the interesting
point is like, how to find out what's the
battery consumption when you use the low level
media API versus the high level API we used
to have.
Um.
One, if you want to do like some filtering
applied to this decoder output, definitely
you can leverage the GPU to do some image
processing so that you can save some power.
In addition to that, you can for example,
if you are writing a streaming application,
you can do smart things like do better buffering.
In terms of using the default buffering mechanism
from the media framework.
So that you can for example, turn off the
radio for better radio usage.
So that you can save some time.
Because for streaming applications, if you
try to get as much as data, as much as possible
at once, and then shut down the radio, and
then after some time you turn on radio and
then do it again.
This can save the power.
So, this is like, a demand issue.
You are using low level media APIs.
On the other hand, this low level media API
because it introduces some like traffic between
the GNI layer and the java layer, so you have
some additional overhead compared to the previous
high level API.
So it's kind of a tradeoff.
If you write a application um, like, uh, a
better or smarter way than probably you can
gain in terms of battery consumption.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
Uh.
Anymore Hangout questions?
>>Male Engineer: Um, not, actually, we do
have one from Jonathan.
I'm gonna put him on in a second.
But why don't you go ahead and answer one
from the Moderator page and I'll put Jonathan
on next.
>>Joe: Sounds great.
So we've got Robin from Georgia who asks,
"I have a live audio feed that I'd like to
stream to Android apps, desktop web browsers
and iOS apps."
The Multiplatform audio feed.
"Do you have a suggestion for a common codec
that could be used if any?"
I'm not familiar enough with audio formats
to answer that one.
Anybody else got a?
>>Trevor: Well.
[laughter]
>>James: Well, for audio streaming you can
come with Android devices like they are multiple
audio codecs are supported.
Like AAC, and AMR narrow band, wide band.
Those can be used for streaming applications.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
I think the constraining factor is not gonna
be the desktop.
Pretty much any audio format you find you'll
be able to play somehow on a desktop.
The tricky part is mobile devices.
Because they have limited capabilities.
And they rely on hardware decoding.
Which means a lot of times you need to have
hardware support.
So take a, I don't think anybody in this room
is, can really speak as to what codecs iOS
supports.
But on Android, I think, yeah, like you said,
AMR and AAC both have pretty wide support
if I remember correctly.
So both of those are a safe bet.
And then from there, find one that works on
iOS.
And the desktop won't be a problem.
>>Joe: Great.
Good answer there.
[inaudible]
>>Male Engineer: Alright, if you guys are
ready for Hangout then I'm gonna go ahead
and put Jonathan on.
>>Trevor: Right, and this'll probably be our
last question I suspect.
>>Joe: Right.
Go ahead Jonathan.
>>Jonathan: Hello, I need to build an application
that reacts to the user input by changing
the music.
And for that I have several music files that
I need to somehow either switch seamlessly
from one to another in a registered manner
so they're, so generally I need to trick the
user in to believing, and into not noticing
that I have changed from one music track to
another.
Since they differ in very small details.
I was wondering what was the best way, if
at all, that I can implement that?
>>Trevor: I think this is sort of related
to the question earlier about how to cross-fade
music as well.
>>Jonathan: yes.
>>Trevor: Was that your question or was that
somebody else?
>>Jonathan: That was not my question.
But this was a good group of questions to
listen in on.
>>Trevor: Right.
So James, do you have any feedback on that?
>>James: Right.
I can provide you a hint.
You can try it out and see whether it works
for you.
Basically we, also in Jellybean we publish
the API, allows you to do gapless playback
for like, audio.
You can try it out.
The API should be available in MediaPlayer.java
class.
Try it out.
Let us know your feedback.
Thank you.
>>Jonathan: Thank you very much.
>>Trevor: That's more for gapless though.
So playing one song and immediately cutting
to the other, right?
>>James: Yeah.
>>Trevor: Is there any way to do a cross-fade
or is that not possible?
>>James: Cross-fade as far as I know, currently
no.
Not possible.
>>Trevor: OK.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Jonathan: Thank you.
>>Joe: Great.
Thanks for the question.
And with that I think we're out of time.
And do you wanna give a little bit of a preview
for what we've got on tap next week?
>>Trevor: Indeed.
So for those of you who are joining us for
the first time, we are on the air every Wednesday
at two pm Pacific time.
So take a look at, actually I guess our Google
plus page is the best place to find us.
Developers.Android, or, developer.Android.com
slash plus.
I believe it's just plural.
There's only one.
>>Joe: Right.
Always.
>>Trevor: Anyway.
Yeah, developer.Android.com slash plus.
You can find links to each broadcast as well
as the Moderator page.
Next week we will have folks from the Android
security team on hand.
Including Kenny Root.
Who will be able to answer all of your questions
about Android security.
So be sure to join us next week.
>>Joe: Great.
>>Trevor: Alright.
With that, I think that's it.
>>Joe: Great.
Thanks for joining us.
See you next week.
>>Trevor: Alright.
See you all next week.
Oh, actually, one last thing.
>>Joe: Uh-oh.
>>Trevor: Thank you to Daniel Pham our engineer
as well as Reto Meier who is the producer
for the show.
And once again, my name is Trevor Johns.
>>Joe: I'm Joe Fernandez.
>>Trevor: And
>>James: James.
>>Trevor: A very special thank you to our
guest.
So, yes.
Thank you James.
Right.
Well, I think that's it.
See you all next week.
>>Joe: Take it easy, thank you.